>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH, JESSICA,
I WANT TO GO "OUTFRONT" NOW AS
PROMISED TO THE JANUARY 6th
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE, BENNY
THOMPSON AND I VERY MUCH
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME.
OBVIOUSLY, SO MANY THINGS TO
ASK.
I DO WANT TO START WITH FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S RESPONSE TODAY
TO THE VIDEO YOU SHOWED A VIDEO
LAST NIGHT A CLIP OF HIS
DAUGHTER IVANKA AND CLEARLY SHE
ACCEPTED THE ELECTION RESULTS
AND THE FORMER PRESIDENT TODAY
SAID THAT IVANKA, QUOTE, WAS NOT
INVOLVED AND HAD LONG SINCE
CHECKED OUT.
DOES HIS RESPONSE AND WHAT HE IS
SAYING CHANGE ANYTHING FOR YOU?
>> NO, IT DOESN'T.
AND BY THE WAY, THANK YOU FOR
HAVING ME.
WE HAVE PROOF ABOUT IVANKA'S
PARTICIPATION WITH HER DADDY ON
A REGULAR BASIS ABOUT WHAT WAS
GOING ON, ON JANUARY 6th.
SHE WAS THERE IN THE WHITE
HOUSE, AND SO WHAT, OR WHO
BETTER COULD HAVE ACCESS TO WHAT
WAS GOING ON THAN ONE'S OWN
DAUGHTER AND SO FOR HIM TO
SOMEHOW INSINUATE THAT HIS
DAUGHTER CHECKED OUT IS
DISINGENUOUS ON HIS PART AS A
FATHER.
DAUGHTERS NORMALLY KNOW WHAT
THEIR FATHERS ARE DOING,
ESPECIALLY WHEN THERE'S A CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP.
>> SO, AS YOU SAY, YOU'VE GOT
THE PROOF THAT SHE WAS INVOLVED
IN BRIEFING HIM ON THOSE
ELECTION RESULTS.
I WANT, ALSO, TO ASK YOU
SOMETHING JESSICA MENTIONED, OF
COURSE, THESE FAR RIGHT
EXTREMIST GROUPS, THE EXTENT TO
WHICH THIS IS PREPLANNED WHICH I
KNOW CHAIRMAN THOMPSON IS CORE
OF THE ENTIRE STORY YOU'RE
TELLING THE COUNTRY.
LAST NIGHT YOU TOLD MY COLLEAGUE
JAKE TAPPER YOU HAVE WITNESSES
THAT WILL DESCRIBE CONVERSATIONS
BETWEEN MEMBERS OF THE EXTREMIST
GROUPS, TALKING ABOUT THE PROUD
BOYS AND OATHKEEPERS,
CONVERSATIONS OF THOSE GROUPS
AND PEOPLE IN THE FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP'S ORBIT.
WHAT WERE THOSE CONVERSATIONS
ABOUT?
WERE THEY SPECIFIC ON THE
PLANNING?
>> WELL, THE PLANNING, THE
CENTERED PRIMARILY AROUND COMING
TO WASHINGTON, SHOWING THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE PRESIDENT AND
BASED ON THAT ENGAGEMENT, THEY
CAME.
THEY CAME IN LARGE NUMBERS.
AS YOU SAW IN THE VIDEO
PRESENTATION, NOT ONLY DID THEY
SET UP OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON,
BUT FOR THE MOST PART, SOME OF
THEM BROUGHT WEAPONS, SOME
BROUGHT TEAR GAS, BEAR SPRAY, A
LOT OF THINGS THAT IS NOT THE
NORMAL THINGS YOU BRING TO A
RALLY OR DEMONSTRATION BUT THEY
BROUGHT KEVLAR VESTS AND OTHER
THINGS AS IF THEY WERE PREPARED
FOR WAR.
BUT MORE IMPORTANTLY, THEY DID
NOT EVEN GO TO THE RLY.
THEY WENT TO THE CAPITOL AND THE
VIDEO DEMONSTRATED ALL OF THAT.
BUT OUR HEARING WILL SHARE THE
OTHER NAMES OF THE OTHER
INDIVIDUALS WHO WERE TALKING TO
THE PROUD BOYS, SOME OF THE
VIDEO YOU SAW THEM MEETING AS A
GROUP WITH OTHER OATH KEEPERS
AND OTHERS.
SO THERE'S A LOT OF SHARING OF
INFORMATION THAT WE WILL PROVIDE
THE PUBLIC WITH DURING OUR NEXT
SIX HEARINGS THAT WILL EVEN
CRYSTALLIZE MORE IN THE MINDS OF
THE PUBLIC AS TO WHAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION DID TO CREATE THE
NARRATIVE FOR JANUARY 6th.
>> SO, I KNOW YOU'RE GOING TO BE
REVEALING A LOT OF THESE NAMES
BUT TO UNDERSTAND WHERE YOU'RE
GOING WITH THIS, WE KNOW A TOP
MEMBER OF THE OATH KEEPERS SAID
IN COURT THAT THE LEADER OF THE
OATH KEEPERS HAD TRIED TO GET IN
TOUCH WITH TRUMP ON JANUARY 6th.
AND THE OATH KEEPER'S LEADER,
ACCORDING TO HIS TESTIMONY,
SPOKE ON THE PHONE TO AN
UNIDENTIFIED PERSON WHO WAS
CLOSE TO TRUMP.
NOW THIS PERSON DID NOT CONNECT
THE LEADER OF THE OATH KEEPERS
TO THE PRESIDENT IN THIS
CONVERSATION AS WE UNDERSTAND
IT.
MY QUESTION FOR YOU, CHAIRMAN
THOMPSON, IS HOW CLOSE WAS THIS
PERSON TO TRUMP?
AND, YOU KNOW, WAS THIS A CORE
INNER CIRCLE PERSON, HAVING A
CONVERSATION WITH A LEADER OF
THE OATH KEEPERS.
>> WELL JUST LET ME SAY IN OUR
INVESTIGATION, WE FOUND CLOSE
RELATIONSHIP WITH THOSE ELEMENTS
IN THE COUNTRY, ESPECIALLY THE
PROUD BOYS AND OATH KEEPERS.
I DON'T WANT TO GIVE HER ALL OF
WHAT WE HAVE.
YOU JUST HAVE TO FOLLOW UP
DURING THE HEARING BUT
EVERYTHING WE PRESENT, WE WILL
BE ABLE TO VERIFY.
IF THERE'S ANYONE WHO DISAGREES
WITH WHAT WE PRESENT, ALL THEY
HAVE TO DO IS COME BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE, TAKE, WE'LL SWEAR
THEM, PUT THEM UNDER OATH, AND
THEY CAN TALK.
THAT'S FROM THE PRESIDENT ON
DOWN.
SO WE WELCOME ANYONE WHO
DISAGREES WITH ANY EVIDENCE WE
PRESENT IN OUR FINDINGS TO COME
TO THE COMMITTEE AND WE WILL
GLADLY ENTERTAIN THEM.
>> SO CHAIRMAN, I GUESS AT THE
CORE OF THIS AND THERE ARE SO
MANY LEVELS OBVIOUSLY IF THE
PRESIDENT NOT QUESTIONED THE
ELECTION, SAID IT WAS RIGGED AND
FRAUDULENT, NONE OF THOSE PEOPLE
WOULD BE HERE TO BEGIN WITH SO
IF YOU LOOK AT RESPONSIBILITY IN
A SIMPLE WAY, YOU'VE LONG AGO
ESTABLISHED ONE DID NOT NEED A
COMMITTEE TO ESTABLISH THAT
LEVEL OF RESPONSIBILITY.
BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THESE
SPECIFIC CONVERSATIONS, ARE YOU
GOING TO BE PRESENTING THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
HIMSELF, PRESIDENT TRUMP AT THAT
TIME, HAVING ANY SPECIFIC
CONVERSATIONS WITH ANY OF THESE
INDIVIDUALS?
>> WELL, NOT THE PRESIDENT.
AS FAR AS, WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
FIND.
BUT THERE ARE PEOPLE, AS I SAID,
IN HIS ORBIT THAT HAVE ENGAGED
THESE GROUPS ALL ALONG.
SO WE WILL BE ABLE TO PRESENT
CERTAIN INFORMATION AROUND THAT.
BUT AS TO WHETHER OR NOT HE WAS
BRIEFED ON WHAT THEY WERE DOING,
WE WON'T GO THAT FAR BUT IT'S
INCONCEIVABLE THAT YOU WOULD
INVITE PEOPLE TO WASHINGTON ON
JANUARY 6th AND TELL THEM IT
WOULD BE WHILE, AS YOU HEARD IN
, THAT IT WOULD BE WILD, AS YOU
HEARD A VIED I WON'T
PRESENTATION, A KIND OF CALL TO
ARMS TO THE RIGHT WING ELEMENT
IN THIS COUNTRY.
SO THE PRESIDENT IS NOTORIOUS
AND CLEAR IN THAT GOING TO BE
WILD TWEET WHAT HE INTENDED TO
SHARE WITH THE PUBLIC.
SO OUR JOB OVER THE NEXT SIX
HEARINGS IS TO TELL THIS STORY.
WE WILL GROW THE PICTURE OF HIM
BEING TOLD BY RESPONSIBLE
INDIVIDUALS THAT THE ELECTION
WAS NOT STOLEN, THEY HAD NOT
FOUND ANY IMPROPRIETY AT ALL IN
TERMS OF THE CONDUCT AND MOST OF
THE AREAS, MOST OF THE OFFICIALS
WERE REPUBLICAN, AND STILL, HE
REFUSED TO ACCEPT HIS DATA
PERSON, HIS CAMPAIGN MANAGER,
HIS CHIEF LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL.
BECAUSE HE KEPT PUSHING THIS
FALSE NARRATIVE ON THE PUBLIC.
HE SPENT MONEY PUSHING THIS
FALSE NARRATIVE.
HE RAISED MONEY TO PUSH THIS
FALSE NARRATIVE, AND WHAT WE'LL
SHOW IN ONE OF OUR HEARINGS AS
TO HOW MUCH MONEY HE REALLY
RAISED, BUT HOW LITTLE HE REALLY
SPENT.
>> BUT HE DIDN'T, HE DID NOT PUT
HIS MONEY WHERE HIS MOUTH IS AS
YOU'RE SAYING.
I ALMOST HESITATE TO ASK THIS
QUESTION TO YOU, CHAIRMAN,
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY, THE FACTS
SHOW THAT WHAT HE SAID HAPPENED
WITH THE ELECTION DIDN'T HAPPEN
AND WAS TOLD REPEATEDLY BY
EVERYONE AROUND HIM SO ANY
STABLE, SANE INDIVIDUAL, YOU
KNOW, SHOULD BE ABLE TO LOOK AT
THE SKY AND SAY OKAY, I KNOW
I'VE BEEN SAYING IT'S GREEN BUT
I GET THE JOKE, I KNOW IT'S NOT
GREEN.
BUT I HAVE TO ASK YOU, DO YOU
HAVE THE PROOF THAT HE DID KNOW
THAT THIS WAS ALL A LIE?
THAT HE KNEW IT WAS ALL B.S.
EVEN AS HE SPREAD IT?
>> WELL, THE ONLY THING WE HAVE
IS THE FIRSTHAND TESTIMONY OF
DIFFERENT WITNESSES FROM, AS I
SAID, HIS OWN ATTORNEY GENERAL,
THE ELECTION OFFICIALS WHO HE
HIRED TO RUN HIS CAMPAIGN.
THOSE ARE HIS TRUSTED ADVISERS.
AND IF THESE ARE THE PEOPLE YOU
HIRE TO ADVISE YOU AND THEY GIVE
YOU THEIR PROFESSIONAL ADVICE
THAT YOU'VE LOST THE ELECTION,
WHY WOULD YOU GO TO THAT RUNT
GROUP OF GIULIANI, POWELL, AND
OTHERS, WHO REALLY ARE JUST
ALONG FOR THE RIDE?
AND START FOLLOWING THEM,
RELEVANT OF PEOPLE YOU'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH ALL ALONG.
EVEN WHEN YOU START GOING TO
COURT, HE WENT TO COURT 60 TIMES
AND HE LOST.
SO AT SOME POINT IN AMERICA,
WHEN YOU LOSE AN ELECTION, AND I
TRIED TO SHOW THAT IN THE TIME
OF THE CIVIL WAR, PRESIDENT
LINCOLN WAS FACED WITH A SIMILAR
SITUATION AND HE RALLIED THE
COUNTRY, RATHER THAN DIVIDE THE
COUNTRY AND SAID IF I LOSE, WE
WILL COOPERATE WITH THE WINNER.
DONALD TRUMP IS THE ONLY
PRESIDENT IN T